kim kardashian and kanye west
appear to be headed for a split and now
a source tells et
that the reality star has considered
divorcing the rapper
and that their marriage counseling
hasn't made much headway
i mean we have different views sometimes
but
that's my husband you know quote she
knows what's best for her and their kids
so if things ended she would want them
to end amicably so they can co-parent
together as best as possible
the source adds that the two have been
living separate lives for months with
kanye staying on their ranch in wyoming
so any issues they're having aren't a
surprise to kim's family
or friends kanye and kim have been
trying to save their marriage but it's
been difficult when he acts out
she is focused on raising her kids and
making sure they're in a safe
stable environment and the source notes
that the kkw beauty founder has felt
overwhelmed
trying to take care of him too that's
not stuff
we put on social media i'm not gonna you
know just start
tweeting what my thoughts are but yeah
we have those moments
meanwhile a second source says that kim
and kanye who have been living in
california
and wyoming respectively have tried
marriage counseling
they've been in it for several months
but aren't making much headway
as a couple it seems the relationship
has run its course
the couple has tried to work on their
relationship for a while but
find it hard to get on the same page the
source adds that they haven't lived
together for some time and have been
focused on their separate businesses
while keeping their children's happiness
at the forefront at the end of the day
life is about being happy
kim and kanye will forever love one
another and will root for each other
i always know his heart so what does
kim's famous fam think of all this
according to a third source there's no
drama between the kardashians and the
rapper
they are amicable and fully aligned when
it comes to the kids
there is no drama or contentious
relationship at
all i feel like we are so blessed to
have the best support system and the
best family
to really just support each other no
matter what we're going through
of course all this comes after a tough
year for the couple
before kanye's controversial and
unsuccessful run for president came to
an end in november
the two were already working on mending
their relationship
following a very public fallout back in
july
when kanye revealed during a political
rally in south carolina
that he and kim had talked about having
an abortion when she was pregnant with
their first child
north so even if my wife were to divorce
me
after this speech she brought north into
the world
even when i didn't want to she stood up
and she protected that child
kanye went on a subsequent twitter rant
of since deleted comments about his wife
and her family
all that led to kim making a lengthy
public statement about her husband's
mental health
and kanye was quick to issue a public
apology to her
he's just the most genuine person
and you know he might say things that
might get misinterpreted and people
don't see the context behind
it and while the two appeared to be
doing better in october during her 40th
birthday getaway on a private island
a source told et in december that they
were still struggling with some
unresolved issues
you